is that what you think
yes
what do you got there
many number rows
frosted numbers
uh i'll give them a try
oh
3d glasses
guess this is my lucky day
can i uh can i see him you can see him
fine from right there
wow
okay you know what fine fine enjoy them
[Laughter]
look arthur it's uh
no big deal but uh
i didn't buy the cereal so technically
those are mine
possession is nine times the law buddy
boy
oh you know what you keep those and i'll
i'll keep the box with the 3d jungle
scene on the back okay
let me see that ah nine tenths of the
law
look at that it's even fun to look at
with plain eyes look at the little
jungle cat wow
maybe we can wipe something out oh
suddenly we're negotiating
don't think so
i'm warning you i'll rip them in half go
ahead big shot
oh that's it
you'll never see this jungle picture
again no more jungle okay
manic there you go huh
you want some cereal
one oh
arthur
didn't i ask you not to put the peanut
butter in the refrigerator yeah
you may have why
because then it gets hard and i can't
spread it without tearing the bread
so just let it sit for a half an hour
and soften up
i want the sandwich now and toast the
bread that way it won't tear
don't want it toasted don't want it in
half an hour what i want is an untoasted
peanut butter and jelly sandwich now
well douglas that might not be possible
as it is i've given you a number of very
attractive alternatives
no they're not attractive okay arthur
you know what i may not be able to
afford a decent car but i do have a
house and i let you live in it so please
show some respect oh peanut butter
peanut butter yes
whoa
didn't know we're going to watch a
motion picture hi dad
you should want a fella when it's movie
night
actually we uh we assumed that you had
other plans well you're in luck tonight
my dance card is wide open
all right so what have we here shoot him
up sci-fi
erotic thriller
it's a mystery i think oh nothing like a
good who done it shh okay here we go
come on
fbi warning
federal law provides severe civil and
criminal
fast forwarding there we go all right
here we go
pentagon
october 1962
on the eve of the cuban missile crisis
arthur
we can read
a thousand pardons
why is that guy shaving his beard
did i get here before you i'm just
trying to follow the story douglas
that's fine just follow it without
talking could you do that snap me him
shhh
[Music]
what did he put into that bed
arthur every time you ask me a question
i can't watch the movie then i don't
know what's going on then you should get
a simpler movie
i'm getting a beer
crack one for me will you yeah
oh sorry darling i didn't realize you
were you're home
hi daddy
heard you and doug had a little
adventure today indeed we did and then
that douglas there's something that
needs to be said
i'm listening
you put a nasty little nick in my
armoire
that's what needs to be said okay you
know what why don't you come inside dad
i'll make you a nice baked apple come on
i realize you were distracted by your
boss's hurtful comments about your
weight but you might be a little bit
more careful in the future your
customers may not be as forgiving as i
am baked apple right this way
arthur do you understand at all that you
almost got me canned you know it's bad
enough that you you trounce all over my
home do you have to trounce on my job
too that's too much trouncing oh you
think this living arrangement is easy
for me you think i like walking around
here on eggshells egg shells is that
what we've been getting here for the
past year eggshell you on eggshells well
thank you for holding back
all right enoch the both of you now
let's all just go inside i will make you
a baked apple i will take a shower
reverse that let's just all go inside
well douglas obviously my living here is
very unpleasant for you
perhaps i should make some other
arrangements
no no no no no i'm interested go on go
where would you go where would you go
come on come on where would you go i
have options options oh so there are
several mental institutions wooing you
i'm just a crazy old man who can't hack
it on my own is that what you think
yes
that's not stopping
well let me tell you something douglas
i've been on my own since i was 17. i
could take care of myself then and i can
take care of myself now
where'd that door go
it's over here dad fine
i'm gonna get my things i'll be staying
at mickey's until i can find a more
permanent situation
arthur what are you doing
what does it look like i'm doing
einstein
it looks like you're unloading dirty
dishes einstein
they're clean einstein no they're dirty
i just loaded them and i went to the
store to get a box of detergent einstein
well why didn't you leave a note saying
that einstein call me einstein stop
calling me einstein
no big deal okay we'll just
reload the dishwasher and
wash them
okay now which which of these did you
already put away
let's see i definitely remember putting
away a blue bowl with big white and
yellow sunflowers on it
okay we don't own anything close to that
we might have a problem
all right then we have no other choice
we're just gonna have to wash everything
we own
[Applause]
this never happened rydo
hello oh hey arthur it's me doug what
can i do you for actually i was just
calling to check the messages off of the
machine so just hang up and i'll call
right back gotcha okay
yellow
arthur didn't i just ask you not to pick
up no you said i should hang up and
you'd call right back
okay what i meant was i wanted the
machine to get it not you i'm trying to
check my messages
you want me to just check them for you
no no thank you no last time you did
that you erased all the messages
end our outgoing messages and unplugged
the lamp
just let it ring okay
it's your world i just live in it
yellow
arthur what did i just say i'm sorry
it's habit well do me a favor break the
habit okay i'm running out of freaking
change here fine
yellow
arthur what is this some kind of sick
little joke
i'm sorry i've been answering the phone
my whole life you're asking me to undo
75 years of instinct in a moment that is
not easy
just don't pick up fine i'm going
downstairs to lie down well thank you
what the yellow is going on in your head
that you keep doing this i need to
understand
douglas i'm mailing some pictures to my
cousin do you think this needs one stamp
or two
around two
what
this seems well within the one house
limit
well then why'd you ask me oh i wanted
an expert opinion but no you had to tow
the company lying you delivery people
got your foot on our throats and you
won't step off
yeah just trying to eat my lunch here
would you forget about food for just one
second okay that's what my sandwich was
missing a finger with a loose band-aid
damn it these are oktoberfest pictures
they have to get to my cousin before
june 1st so then put two stamps on them
put ten on what are you kids i like you
paying for them
how dare you
[Applause]
hey guys
yeah well how about this huh
douglas will you please pass the ketchup
the what the ketchup
you mean the ketchup
educated people pronounce it catsup
not if they want me to pass it to them
fine if that's where you're gonna be
then i'll do without
not gonna happen old man
my burger's getting cold just give me
the ketchup okay it's called ketchup say
it right and you can have it no say it
say it no i will never say it i'd rather
die than say it
but she's staying over here
miami catcher
fine
and just say goodbye to these
why are you gonna do that all right you
want the cats if you can have the cats
up here
good
all right
thank you that's enough okay
that's enough that's that's enough
that's enough
that's enough oh is that enough yes
that's enough that's enough then say it
say that say it what say it hey what's
it called
ketchup
and that's how we learn
my eyes are getting weary
my back
i'm is here in traffic on the
queensborough bridge tonight
but i don't care cause all i wanna do
is catch my check and drive right home
to you